[Musique]
dans un rapport salé la cour des comptes
par la voix de son président pierre
moscovici vient d'épingler et de pointer
plusieurs échecs du rsa d'abord près de
30% de celui endroit six cent mille
ménages n'y ont pas recours la faute
notamment à un défaut d'information
malgré cette aide les bénéficiaires
rencontrerait d'énormes difficultés 43%
du mal à se chauffer 30 % se
restreignent pour acheter de la viande
est autant déplore des découverts
bancaires fréquents le rapport pointe
également du doigt les départements et
pôle emploi censé prendre en charge un
suivi faire signer un contrat
d'engagement et ainsi faciliter un
retour à l'emploi des bénéficiaires
le rapport constate que seuls 40 %
auraient signé le contrat dans des
délais largement supérieurs à ceux
prévus et dans 76% des cas les contrats
selon les mots de la cour des comptes ne
contiennent aucune action visant à
inscrire les personnes dans un parcours
de recherche d'emploi bref des échecs
flagrants pointé dans un rapport qui
tombe justement alors qu emmanuel macron
a ramené sur la table le 6 janvier
dernier son nouveau dispositif le revenu
universel d'activité r u à fusionner le
rsa l'apl aide personnalisée au logement
et la prime d'activité une proposition
qui sera sans doute un élément phare du
programme du futur candidat macron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]